Hello, once again,
everybody. My name is
Dr. Richard Morgan, and
here we are presenting.
I will be taking you
through the second
of three DPR neurologic
exams. Today will
be the second portion
of our three-part
series, including motor
system, coordination,
gait, reflexes, as
well as some special
techniques that will go
on at the afterwards.
similar to the previous
objectives these
objectives will involve
reviewing the screening
of the neurologic
examination performing
an assessment of
the motor system
coordination gait
reflexes as well as some
special techniques and
how to document the
findings we will have
similar slides as we had
on the first lecture
series where we have
demonstrations and
examples of documentation
now again neurologic
exam as i showed
this before this is
more of a a rehashed
slide that starts with
patient history. What
are the important
components of the
neurologic exam? How do
we do a detailed HPI,
history of present
illness, and focus it on
the neurologic exam?
That's when a patient
presents with one or
more of the following
symptoms. And like
I said before, this
is not an all-inclusive
or exhaustive list,
but more than more
common presentations.
They include headache,
dizziness, vertigo,
weakness of an
extremity, Possible
numbness or tingling
or any abnormal
absence, sensation
in the arms or legs,
neurosyncope or syncope,
sort of passing out,
a history of
seizures recently,
and then possibly
some tremors
or involuntary movements.
Components of a
screening exam, as gone
through before, I
won't rehash it, but
please use this for
your references.
It includes all
the base components
of this neurologic
screening exam
as I went over on
the first slide.
And then from the first
lecture, I
talked to this.
Now, motor system, okay?
Motor pathways involve
both upper motor
neurons that will
synapse with lower motor
neurons and then to the
peripheral structures,
which terminate in the
neuromuscular junction,
okay?
Now, it's broken up
into two components,
both the upper and the
lower motor neurons.
Now, you're gonna
get a lot of this in
neuroanatomy. My job
isn't gonna be to go over
all this detail specifically.
This is more for
referencing, but what's
important is, and
you can read the
definitions here, I want you
to start to learn and
appreciate how these
upper motor neuron
presentations, if you
will, from a patient
perspective will present
in a physical exam, how
doing certain physical
exam skills will
present, and depending on
how they are demonstrating
will determine
if they're either
positive or negative, or
either an upper or lower
motor neural lesion.
Again, motor
function involves
three principal
motor pathways,
including the
corticospinal or frontal
tracts, the cerebellar
system, and the basal
galleon system. Again,
much of this will
be found in your
neuroanatomy lectures.
again principal motor
pathways are labeled
here and displayed
for your purposes it's
important to know this
again for purposes
of dpr i'm going to
be spending more time
on the components of
the physical exam and
you'll start to as
you pick up through
the course of this
semester start to really
start to put together
the clinical correlations
with the
pathophysiology and that
will really give you
much more detail and
that's really what the
boards love to do on
their on their concept
questions as well.
Two of the other
principal motor pathways
include, like I
said, the basal
ganglion system as
well as cerebellar.
Basal ganglion helps
maintain muscle tone
and control body
movements, such as walking,
and cerebellar
receives sensory
motor input that
coordinates motor
activity, maintaining
equilibrium
and assistive
and show posture.
We're going to have,
I'm going to go over
very specific ways we're
going to demonstrate
this in DPR and some
of the physical exams
that we'll be practicing
over and over.
Upper and lower motor
neural lesions, they're
basically labeled
out here. And this is
an important slide
because it helps kind
of bring everything
together, if you will.
What kind of lesions,
how do we determine
if there's a lesion,
and what physical
signs do we find on a
physical exam that help
us kind of demonstrate
that there is an
upper motor neuron lesion.
So as it says here,
if there's the UMN
system is damage that
occurs above the
crossover in the medulla,
motor impairment,
weakness, and paralysis is
on the contralateral
side, right? So if the
upper motor neuron
system damage occurs
below the crossover in
the medulla, then motor
impairment is ipsilateral
on the same side,
okay? Other forms of
upper motor neural
lesions can display
a spasticity or angle
clonus, which we can get
into it a little bit.
Muscle tone is increased.
Deep tendon reflexes, which
we'll be demonstrating
in a little bit, they're
more exaggerated,
meaning what we
call hyperreflexia.
Okay. And then finally,
Babinski's sign, which
we use to determine upper
motor neural lesions,
oftentimes in someone
who's exhibited a
****** or other kind of
significant neurologic
injury, is a test for
literally an upper
motor neural lesion,
and the foot will go
over that as well. And
then finally, the lower
motor neural lesions.
What does that involve?
Mostly motor impairment
with weakness and
paralysis on the hips
lateral side. And this
is demonstrated in
the physical exam by
atrophy or muscle tone
is down. The reflexes
that we'll be demonstrating
are all decreased
or hyperreflexive or
possibly even absence.
Muscle mass is
atrophic. It's weakened
or damaged. And
oftentimes this is due
to a damage to the
innervating nerve
to that muscle or
possibly something
from the cervical
or the lumbar spine.
And then finally,
fasciculations or an
irritated nerve root,
a peripheral nerve root
generally, are also
signs of lower motor
neural antigens. Now,
why is this important?
Many specific
disease processes are
labeled or categorized,
if you will, as
upper or lower motor
neural antigens.
Some have both. I'll
give you a classic
example. I'll give
you a moment to think
and give you one classic
example that contains
both upper and motor
neural lesions.
Well, the example I
was thinking of was
amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis or Lou Gehrig's
disease. One of the
classic distributions
or presentations of
Lou Gehrig's disease
is signs of both
upper and lower motor
neural lesions in the
disease process. Of
course, there's other
things component, but
as you can imagine,
it's a very disabling
and likely disease
with a very, very high
mortality rate. So it's
important to diagnose
these things. But
it just goes to the
importance of why we
want to go examine and
really understand the
clinical correlations
between the physical
exams that we perform
and trying to
determine if there are
either upper or low in
motor narrow lesions.
Just a few other
examples. Lesions to
the cortical spinal
tract. Basal ganglion
or cerebellar systems,
the corticospinal
tract, we often see
weakness, right? So
weakness in any
muscles, ipsilateral,
can be both sides,
but oftentimes one as
well, depending on
the disease process.
Basal ganglion will also
do changes in
muscle tone,
often increased
disturbances in posture
and gait, or slowness
or lack of spontaneous
or automatic
movements, including in
various involuntary
movements. And we'll go
through this when we
go over some of the
other examples of
physical examination.
Finally, cerebellar
system lesions will
include impairment
of coordination,
gait, equilibrium,
as well as decreased
muscle tone. And we
will have some very
specific cerebellar
physical exam
skills that we'll be
practicing as well.
Now, muscles.
Well, how do
we assess muscles? Okay.
Just as we always did
in the past, we want
to observe. We want
to inspect. Look at
the body at rest so
that there's no force.
There's no contractile
movement put on these
muscles. How does the
body look at rest?
Are there any
involuntary movements?
Do you notice any
tremors, tics, or
fasciculations?
Ask the patient if
they've ever noticed
anything before.
What describes
the muscle bulk?
Is it symmetrical?
Is there any
noted unilateral
or bilateral
atrophy or wasting?
Muscle tone.
Assessing the muscle's
resistance, passive
stretch. Okay, and
we go into this
with active and passive
range of motion.
As well as muscle
strength by asking
patients to actively
resist your movement.
Now, you might be
thinking, why is it so
important to include
the motor system here
in the neurologic
lecture? Well, I'm going
to tell you. We're
going to cover the
MSK, the musculoskeletal
system, in much more
detail later in the
semester. But the
reason we need to
incorporate it here is
because oftentimes
specific focal motor
deficits can correlate
directly and give us
insight, not only if
it's upper versus lower
motor neural lesions,
but really isolate
us to a specific
level of the cervical
and or lumbar spine,
most likely to correlate
specific with
clinical disease. For
instance, someone who
has muscle wasting or
atrophy of a calf muscle
can often associate
it with specifically
an S1 nerve root.
So knowing motor
system and how it
correlates to
neuromuscular is vital to
understand the
neurosystem as well.
Here's an example
of muscle atrophy.
The first two slides
in the upper left here,
you'll notice it's a 44
-year-old, good muscle
bulk, good tone in the
fingers, everything
looks good. There's
no signs of any kind
of focal atrophy or
wasting in the muscles.
Now note the 84-year
-old who does exhibit
some atrophy. You
can see this is an
exaggerated case,
but it really goes
to show you what
happens when you have
isolated muscle
wasting or gross muscle
wasting of specific
areas. note the
interosseous muscles
in the fingers that
are atrophic, as well
as the hypothenar
atrophy noted in
the thumb there as
well, as well as
the venar cladding.
And it's important
to document this
very, very
specifically in your
notes, because again,
it goes towards
what could be causing
this atrophy. Is it
unilateral? Is it
bilateral? And due to the
increased number of
muscles involved is likely
more than what they're
involved as well.
Motor system. Now,
how do we break down
motor system? Motor
weakness, okay, or
muscle weakness,
I should say, is
always going to be
labeled as one of two
things. It's either
proximal or distal.
Proximal refers
to the peripheral
limbs that are
closest to the axial
spine. So in this
case, Shoulder
and hip girdle
would be proximal.
Distal would be the
hands and the feet.
Identify by asking
about difficulty combing
hair. How can we ask
or incorporate whether
or not a patient
might be exhibiting
proximal motor weakness?
You ask them about their
social or ADLs. How
do they take care of
ADLs, which is activities
of daily living?
Do they have difficulty
bathing, feeding,
dressing, such as
combing their hair?
Do they have any
difficulty making
or drinking coffee
in the morning?
Ask them about
simple tasks,
that things that can
be not as challenging
for many people, but it
can be really challenging
for people struggling
with this. And
it's really important
to get a good baseline.
Proximal muscles
help you get in
and out of a chair
or climb stairs.
You know, getting
an idea of their
surroundings at home,
give you an insight
as to whether or
not they're going to
be continually
struggling with their
activities of daily
living down the line.
Distally, all right,
hands and feet.
ask about hand
strength when opening
a jar or tripping
when walking? Do they
stumble over
themselves when they
cross the street?
Have they ever had
any kind of history
of falls recently?
And if so, how
many? And if so, do
they recall how they
might have fallen?
You know, it's one
thing it, you know,
it just happened
suddenly or if someone
pushed you, but
obviously tripping or
not remembering why
you fell is important
to always consider
that there could
be a component of
weakness. And then here
we go with muscle
strength abnormalities.
These are some
basic definitions.
Paralysis, absence
of strength.
Pharesis is where
strength is impaired.
Hemiparesis is
weakness, usually
unilateral, to
one side of the
body, such as with
a CVA or ******.
Hemiplegia is paralysis
to one side of
the body, and so
on and so forth. I
won't go through the
list, but you have
them here for your
edification, and
please use them as
for your references.
So this is a common
muscle strength scan
that we'll be using when
we do physical exams
and do motor strength
testing throughout
our time in the spring
semester within the
DPR lab. So it really
is important because
each time you examine
and test motor strength
of a specific muscle
group, you need to
document clearly exactly
what the motor strength
was for each muscle
counting. And it
can be done, if it's
all normal, it can be
done written out very
easily and succinctly.
so understanding the
strength scale is
vital here zero being
no muscle contraction
is detective and five
is active movement
against full resistance
so the three most
important are zero
three and five and
everything else can
be kind of inferred
from there so zero no
muscle contraction five
is full motor strength
with full resistance
three is active
movement against
gravity so what that
means is the patient
can hold their hand
up or leg up against
gravity, but that's
it. Anytime you place
any kind of pressure
on it, it collapses.
So two would be active
movement with gravity
eliminated, where
they really can't even
hold it up with
gravity eliminated. So
they really do struggle
with that as well.
And then four would
be some resistance
against gravity, but
not full resistance is
noted. So you'll get a
lot of practice doing
this. We're going
to do this in all of
our individual pods
when we practice this
spring semester, both
in the neuro labs as
well as in the MSK
musculoskeletal labs
as well. So please get
familiar with this.
Upper extremities
include motor strength,
flexion, extension.
Now this is going
to be a list of slides
that, as I said,
every time you do
a strength testing,
you're correlating
specifically with usually
a nerve group,
okay? In this case,
upper body motor
strength testing, we're
checking for elbow
flexion or extension.
Flexion is going
to tell us C5, C6.
Newer roots, if
there's any kind of
weakness, then we'll know
where that's coming from.
Extension involves spinal
innervations of
C6, 7, and 8.
So please note the
pictures and how you
present and how you
stand in front of
the patient. And
once again, we'll go
through this in lab.
You inform the patient
exactly what you're
going to be doing,
you are allowed to
do them symmetrically
and bilaterally at the
same time. Totally fine
with that. For practice
purposes, as you
get familiar with, you
can certainly start
with one side at a
time and then move into
bilateral approach
towards physical exam
testing. But you want
to check it bilaterally.
I like doing it at
the same time because
if there's any kind of
very subtle difference
between a four out
of five or a five out
of five. You'll really
notice that subtle
difference as you do
them simultaneously.
So oftentimes, you
can get a little
bit better
inference as to what
the diagnosis is
based on that.
Again, moving on to the
shoulders, the spinal
nerve innervation is
also C5, C6 in the
axillary nerve. What
we do here is we have a
patient raise their arm.
You can have them put
their elbows straight
out, and you have
them, and you apply a
resistance as they elevate
their arm against
your palm as you press
firmly down. Again, for
demonstration purposes,
it's shown here
unilaterally, but of
course, as I said, totally
fine as you get more
comfortable to do this
bilaterally as well.
Here we go with the
wrist, wrist flexion
and extension. The
flexion is innervated by
six, seven of the
median nerve. Having the
patient make a fist
and then having the
patient flex their wrist
down against resistance
while you're pushing
upward. As you can
see, the upward arrow
in the top picture
is the examiner applying
an upward resistance,
and the downward
arrow is the patient
applying a downward
resistance. So you can
see how the two work
together hand in hand.
Extension, just the
opposite. Now the
instructor is applying
a downward resistance
with the patient resistance
as it goes upward.
And again, these can
be done one-sided
at a time. It's good
practice that way. As
you get better, you
can start to do them
symmetrically, especially
if there's subtle
differences that you're
looking for to examine
any focal motor
weakness in the wrist.
Finger motor strength
can be done here. We
have AD duction and
AB duction. AD duction
involves C78T1. And then
here you simply have
the patient has to
squeeze your fingers as
hard as they can and
they'll let go. Finger
AB duction, where you
apply resistance as
the patient spread
their fingers and band
them outward, and you're
applying a resistance,
bringing them together,
having the patient
try to prevent any
movement that you do.
Again, finger AB
duction is CAT1,
no longer. So really,
these are great
tests to help
get confirmation.
If you feel, for
instance, there's an
ulnar neuropathy or
any kind of weakness,
or slowing along
the ulnar nerve, you
want to determine
where the lesion is.
So you can test in
different places.
And one thing is a
10L sign, which we'll
show you later on
in the next lecture,
where you tap
on the elbow.
And then, again, for
confirmation sake, you
can also test finger
abduction, which is
another branch of the
ulnar nerve as well.
Thumb opposition
is very important.
Motor strength for the
spinal nerve roots.
It innervates CAT1
in the median nerve.
But for here, as you
see in the picture, you
have the patient
touch the tip of your
finger with their thumb
against resistance.
Very important to check
for thumb opposition.
Again, very, very
important as it
involves branches of
the brachial plexus and
other distal nerve
roots from there on in.
Let's go on to some lower
extremity motor
strength testing.
We'll start with hip
flexion and extension.
Hip flexion involves
nerve roots L2, 3, and 4.
And as you can see
demonstrated here, you
have the patient line
supplying on their
back, and you have
them tell them what
you're doing, and
you have them elevate
their hip against
resistance to your hand.
And then this way,
again, you can
also test for
strength testing from
that. This is a
little harder to
do bilaterally
at the same time,
So kind of doing
it side to side is
the way to go with
this and checking
for motor strength
testing here.
Extension,
same thing. You just
put your hand underneath
and you have them
bear down or push
down on your palm
into the table. It's
all in how you describe
the patient doing
it. Very simple and
easy is one way to
do it in this regard.
So you can even have
the patient, it's
not demonstrated in
this bottom picture.
You can even have
them slide to the edge
of the table a little
bit more and have
them push down your
hand that way. either
way is preferable.
Low extremity hip AD
and AB duction, okay?
Spreading out the
hips and bringing them
together. AD duction
is coming together.
So that's L2-3-4 in
nerve root innervations.
What we do is we
place our hands on the
inside of the knees
and have the patient
bring their legs together
against resistance,
check for the
adductor muscles. And
then secondly, the
AB ductors, which is
L45S1, you have the
patient place your hands
on the outside of the
patient's knees and
structure to spread
their legs apart
against resistance. A lot
of different components
here showing all the
various examples.
We will be practicing
this all in lab.
And once you get
comfortable in doing
this, it can be done
very, very efficiently
and not too much
time needs to be
taken. We've done
very, very efficiently.
Lower extremities,
including motor
strength testing of
knee flexion extension.
Straightforward, you
have the patient sit
up with their legs
hanging over the table.
Flexion includes spinal
nerve roots
L5, S1, and S2.
Patient is instructed
to pull or flex their
leg against resistance.
What you're doing
testing is the
hamstring muscles here.
Those are those
innervations.
Extension will involve
the quads, which is
L2, 3, and 4. And
this is where you have
the patient. And I like
to do it simultaneously,
pushing against
resistance into your
hands. I like this
simultaneously because
oftentimes it's a
very, very easy way to
notice any subtle
changes in any kind of
weakness on one side
versus the other. You
may have five over
five on the right leg,
but the left leg
would just be a little
bit less like a four
or four plus over five.
So getting that subtle
difference, it's
a nuance, but you don't
always get to easily
pick it up. Unless
you've done the test
a thousand times, it's
much easier to pick
up when you're doing
it simultaneously.
Moving on to the
ankles, we have two
major motions we
check for the ankles,
dorsi and plantar
flexion. Dorsi flexion
involves the innervation
of nerve root
cell 4-5. It's where
you have the patient
lift their toes up
against resistance,
and then you apply
a downward push.
Plantar flexion
involves S1, one
of the more common
nerve roots involved
with back pain.
So it's an
important test to
know and how to do.
Nice and easy
way to tell a
patient is that
you just have
them push down
on a gas pedal.
Once you have them
push down, you
apply a gentle
resistance and then
you will know if
there's any kind of
weakness in that
plantar flexion.
Next, let's move
on to coordination.
So coordination
for muscle
movements requires
the following.
Motor system, which
includes muscle strength.
Vestibular
system, which is a
component of balance,
coordination of
eyes, head, and
body movements.
Sensory system,
including position sense.
And then the cerebellar
system, finally, which
integrates the
information to produce
normal rhythmic movements
and steady posture.
So coordination is
just about one thing.
It's very multifaceted.
It's a combination
of multiple things
working at once.
You know, a lot of
times we tend to take
these for granted.
But really, it's
quite an amazing system
that the body has
set up for us to
always be on our toes.
How do we assess
coordination?
Well, we observe
patient performing
various types of
movements, and
these are some
of the tests that
we're going to be
doing in class.
One of the tests is
rapid alternating
movements,
which tests for
diatokinesis. Now,
what's diatokinesis?
Excuse me. It's
the ability to make
antagonistic movements
in a quick succession,
alternately
bringing a limb into
opposite positions,
such as flexion or
extension or pronation
and supination.
The example we'll
be using here is
slapping your hand,
supinating the pronating
on one side versus
the other side.
If there is a
lesion or the
patient is unable
to perform the
feet, then that
would be called
dysdiatokinesis, where
there is an actual
deficit or inability
for the patient to
perform that rapid
alternating movement.
Another example of
coordinating movements
is point-to-point
movement. Most
commonly, what we
use is finger to
nose, and we'll go
over that. And then
some other gait and
other related body
movements we'll be
covering as well.
Okay. Let's start
with rapid alternating
movements. Like you
said, the example I have
here is rapid
alternation of pronation
of one hand with
supination on the other.
The fingers touch the
thumb to each finger
quickly. And you can
see the example in
the middle picture
there where the patient
is touching each
finger to their thumb.
One, two, three, four,
one, two, two, three,
four, and then repeat
that very quickly.
And then the legs, the
patient can tap with
the floor or examinations,
hands with the
ball, and look quickly,
as you see here.
Not all three needs
to be performed.
If you suspect
difficulty or problems
with the patient
being able to
complete one, then
I would do a second.
But the whole thing is
at least pick one that
you're comfortable
with. And like I said,
the rapidly alternating
pronation and
supination is one
that's very easily
reviewed and
commonly used.
And again, just
observing for speed,
rhythm, and smoothness
of the movements.
Here's an example of
the point-to-point
movements with both arms
and legs. For the arms,
we use finger to
nose. You might have
seen this in the past.
You can see the patient
is instructed to
touch the physician's
finger and then touch
their nose. Each time
that they do it, the
physician or the examiner
will move their
finger to a different
point in time, and the
patient has to keep
being able to coordinate,
meaning touch their
nose and touch the finger
in the new location.
And observing for
smoothness and accuracy
is important here.
Patient unable to do
this may have some
deficit or lesion that
needs to be further
evaluated and assessed.
Secondly, we have
the legs, which is a
leg heel shin
movement, and we'll
practice this in lab
as well. Patient places
one heel on the
opposite knee and
slide it down the
shin of the other leg.
They should be able
to do this freely
without any difficulty.
Again, any kind of
deficit should be
followed up closely.
Next, let's look at
some gait techniques.
What is gait?
Gait analysis is
so important, and
it goes through
a lot of
different things.
Determining how
someone walks
can tell you a
lot about the type
of diagnosis
that they have.
Unforwarded gaits
can increase the risk
of falls. It's
so, so important,
especially when you're
dealing with the
elderly population
or people who are at
risk knowing their
living situation at
home really need to
do risk prevention.
An uncoordinated
gait can lead to
unnecessary increased
risk in falls and
potentially worse,
such as hip fractures,
which can certainly
significantly
worsen a patient's
morbidity and mortality.
An ataxic gait, which
is an uncoordinated
gait, which is unstable,
can be seen in some
cerebellar diseases
or even an intoxicated
state or a loss of
physician sense as well.
How do we evaluate it?
Well, one thing I like
to do, and I always
recommend to medical
students to do this as
you get more comfortable,
especially in your
preclinical rotations
or if you're shadowing
doctors, I love to see
the patient walk in
the room when they're
not even knowing that
we're paying attention.
It's kind of like
watching them from the
third eye, right? Just
watching them walk.
They don't know they're
being watched, but you
can tell a lot about
to see if there's any
kind of, you know,
limp or circumducted
gait or any
difficulty with them
with transfers as
well. But watching
their gait is very
vital to understanding
their diagnosis.
Watch them across
the room down a hole.
You're observing for
posture, balance and
swinging with the arms
and leg movements.
Normal intact balance,
arms swing symmetrically
at the sides and
turns are smooth,
okay? Another way we
examine their gait is
you have them tandem
walk, meaning foot
over toe, foot over
toe in a straight line.
The ability to do
this can include
some form of ataxia
not otherwise
seen, but it is
important to demonstrate
proper coordination
in patients.
Then you can also have
them walk on their heels,
toes on heels,
hop in one place,
or do a shallow
knee bend.
All these not only
test a little bit
of strength, but
more importantly,
the coordination
and the ability for
patients to
independently ambulate
and really being
able to isolate those
patients that are at
risk for future falls.
Okay, let's talk
about some reflexes.
This may be the
earliest and most
subtle indication
of a neurological.
Reflexes are an
involuntary response to a
sensory stimulus where
abnormalities are
difficult to simulate.
So it's a really
good test. You're going
to be doing this a
ton of times, not only
practicing them in
the lab over and over
again, but you're
going to be doing
these on rotations. It
doesn't matter what
rotation you're on, from
surgery to internal
medicine to OB and
down the line. I know
you've got a couple
of years to go, but
it's important to keep
these components that
reflexes are going
to be very prevalent
in whatever type of
physical exam skills
you'll be performing.
Reflexes can be
motor, sensory, or
autonomic. They can also
involve a stimulation
of receptors, such
as skin, mucous
membranes, muscle,
periosteum, and
retina, as well as
viscera. And we'll go
over the different
types of reflexes.
Some we will be
performing in lab,
and some we're
just going to be
discussing for
obvious reasons, but
I'll go into them
later as well.
What types of
reflexes exist? One of
the most common ones
that we will be doing
and testing in
lab are the muscle
stretch reflexes or
the DTRs, the deep
tendon reflexes.
This is a protective
function, especially
with standing and
walking, and involves
specific spine
segments and a simple
monosynaptic reflex.
Another form of a
reflex is a cutaneous
reflex, elicited by
a superficial skin
stimulus and occurs in
the same general area.
And then third type
of reflex is primitive
reflexes. We won't
be really going into
them now. We're going
to be covering them
in infant and pediatrics
when we get to
those lectures in
the very near future.
Reflexes are described
and categorized
in two ways. They're
either increase or
decrease, right? So
increase we refer to
as hyperreflexia or
hyperactive reflexes.
Hyperreflexia, as
I sort of mentioned
before, if you go back
to your upper motor
neuron lesions,
is a lesion of the
descending cortical
spinal tract, which is a
sign of an upper
motor neuron lesion.
That's the key clinical
correlation here.
When someone's hyperreflexic,
it can indicate
hyperreflexia,
and it needs to be
clinical correlated
with the rest of the
exam to determine the
cause and diagnosis.
Upper motor neuron
lesions, findings of
weakness, spasticity,
or even a plasma
bensky can also be
found. So that's hyper.
Hyporeflexia involves
hypoactive or
even absent
reflexes. These are
lesions of spinal
nerve roots. They're
lower motor neuron
lesions, oftentimes
involving spinal
nerve plexuses,
such as the brachial
plexus or even
peripheral nerves.
Lower motor neuron
lesions include
weakness, atrophy, and as
I said before,
fasciculations, which
is an irritated
peripheral nerve root.
How do we grade deep
tendon reflexes? So
you remembered your
motor strength testing
and the grading
there. This grading is
a little different,
but it's very important
to know because you're
going to be using
this in all your
notations when you
write SOAP notes for
neurologic testing. The
scale is graded from
zero to four, okay?
Two is average. So
most times, if you're
examining a patient
with normal reflexes,
you can simply say
two plus bilateral,
right? Four would
be hyperactive,
extremely brisk with
possible clonus.
Excuse me. So what's
clonus? It's a rhythmic
oscillation between
flexion extension.
Essentially, it's a
neurologic condition that
can also cause not
just rhythmic muscle
contractions, but also
relaxations of the
ankle joint. It's often
triggered by a stimulus
that can appear as a
series of herky-jerky
movements with a large,
noticeable bounce.
It's important. You
won't see it often, but
when you see it,
you'll never forget it.
So that's what a
hyperactive or 4-plus reflex
would look like. So
2 is average, 4 is
brisk, 3 is a little bit
more than average, but
certainly not reaching
that hyperactive
state that I just
described. And then finally,
one is somewhat diminished
than normal, lower
than normal, and zero
is absent reflexes.
Again, they're documented
one plus through
four plus.
Very important.
We see this a
lot, and please
keep this in
mind when you're
practicing these
skills in lab.
A lot of times you'll
see, oh, my God,
Dr. Morgan, I can't
get a reflex on this
particular D10 reflex
with a knee **** on
the left or the right.
The bottom line is
you're going to see
some patients that
have physiologically
low reflexes. It's
very easy to have that.
We're mostly looking
for symmetry. If
you see something
that's way out of line
or abnormal, everything
also has to be
clinically correlated.
So you might have
a patient who is
completely normal, no
significant medical
history, but they
come in and you notice
they have decreased
diminished reflexes,
but it's symmetrical.
No need to
do any further
evaluation if there's
nothing else present
on a physical exam.
Here's an example of
the reflex hammers
you'll be using. These
are all the different
types we have. Most
likely, you'll be
using the one on
the left. That comes
with most of your kits
that you purchased,
although some of
the other ones do
contain the later
models that you
see in the middle
on the right.
Detailed reflex
procedures. This could vary
based on the different
reflexes that we're
testing, but we need
to get the patient to
relax. Most important,
any kind of muscle
movement or contraction
can often diminish the
reflex response. So
the hammer needs to be
held loosely between
your thumb and dwarfing,
or very lightly, like
an arc. It needs to
be able to swing freely
within the limits
of your palm and fingers.
And we'll be practicing
this plenty of times
in lab, so you'll
get a lot and a lot
of practice with this.
Now, using this
technique listed below
for patients who have
symmetrically diminished
traps and reflexes,
meaning sometimes
patients, no matter
what you do, you
can't get a response
and you start to get
freaked out. They're
like, what do I do?
So what we do
is we try to
use a distractor
technique.
This is going to be
done in lab and we'll
have one of the
academic scholars
actually demonstrate
this on the stage. You
distract the patient
from muscle contraction
by having them
put their hands in
a fist position,
holding their hands. And
then on a count of
three, you have them
pull apart and they
just pull on their
arms, as you can see,
designated by the
two black arrows in
the bottom picture.
As they're pulling
apart on the count of
three, not releasing,
just pulling very
tightly apart. that's
when you elicit
the knee reflex,
as you see with the
example with the
hammer there on the
patient's right knee.
And you'll notice that
if you've gotten
over a reflex before,
oftentimes you get a
significant response.
Students always love
this because it's
amazing when they're
practicing it, they can't
get a response. And
then once you use
this simple distracting
technique, it often
works very well. And
again, we'll have plenty
of time to practice
assist in the lab.
Biceps include the spinal
nerve roots of C5 and 6.
Again, the most important
thing to know with
the bicep is that
you want to use your
thumb and use it and
place it on the bicep
tendon when you're
using the hammer. The
reason for this is patient
comfort, number one,
and also sometimes the
contractile response
you get from the
bicep tendon can be
very subtle, and you
may not actually see the
arm flex, but you'll
feel a mild contraction
underneath your
thumb. Either one is a
normal response. So
it's important to do
this this way and do
it bilaterally as well.
Brachioradialis
includes spinal nerve
roots five and six.
Again, this is about
located one or two
inches above the wrist.
As you can see, no
thumb is required. A
simple tapping with
the patient in the
radial position, okay,
thumb up, and a very
light tap, and you'll
see a nice little
twitch with a radial
deviation of the
arm. Oftentimes, it
can be very subtle,
so you got to look
for it very carefully.
Deep tendon
reflexes of tricep
and quads. We
have the tricep,
which is nerve
root six to seven.
As you see in the
picture, you have the
patient relax with their
arm flexed downward,
and you have to
completely isolate the
tricep tendon as it
inserts into the elbow.
You apply in that
arc that we described
before, the hammer
comes right on
the insertion of where
the tricep tendon,
the tricep inserts
into the elbow.
And again, you assess
it bilaterally.
Next is the quads.
Telereflex, spinal
nerves, two, three, and
four are involved.
This is done with the
patient generally sitting
up, although it doesn't
have to be. And as
you can see, you want
to isolate simply by
having the patellar
tendon tapped using the
reflex hammer and doing
that on bilateral.
Again, if there's any
kind of diminished
response, you can use the
distractor technique
as I described before.
Deep tendon reflexes
on the ankle will
involve nerve roots
S1. This is where very,
very important,
especially for your
testing when we do
practical assessments in
lab. Please note to
always, always, always
remove the shoes
and socks. It's not
just enough to pull
it down a little bit.
Any kind of
clothing on that
area can make it
difficult to get or
elicit even if it's a
subtle response. And
proper exam technique
involves removing
shoes and socks.
The examiner will
dorsiflex the patient's
foot, and then the
Achilles tendon is struck
with the reflex hammer,
you get a nice general
response where the
foot will kind of move
in a plantar flexed
or downward position.
I mentioned before
ankle clonus.
This is tested
when the reflex
appears to be
hyperactive.
If you take the knee
and support it in this
position and you apply
a dorsiflex response,
you want to do it
sharp very rapidly.
What you'll notice is
if clonus is present,
And it'll have this
sort of rhythmic muscle
contraction and relaxation
in an oscillating
almost technique.
Very, very classic
when you see it. It
doesn't happen a lot. But
when you see it, you
will never forget
it. And this must be
present in order to grade
a stretch muscle
reflexes or four plus.
Some of the other
tests that we do
want you to be aware
of, they can be
done on rotations.
But please keep
in mind, we will
not test them here.
These are elicited
by superficial skin
stimuli and occur in
the same general area.
These include the
**** reflex, the
cremasteric reflex, and
the abdominal reflex.
Can anyone think of
a diagnosis or some
time where you
actually do need to
check one or more of
these? I'll give you
a minute. I'll give
you five seconds.
Okay. Well,
one condition,
and I, being a PM
&R physician myself,
one of the main
tests we use
these for is
assessing level of
paralysis in
spinal cord injury.
All these are very,
very vital to determine
the level of injury
in a spinal cord
patient. And oftentimes,
we used to do either
one or most commonly,
so don't think they're
not done. They're not
done regularly, but
they are very, very
important to know,
especially depending
on the rotation and the
diagnosis that you're
trying to look for.
Primitive reflexes,
just a list. We're not
going to be doing
them at this time, but
we will cover them in
pediatrics. They're
not present in
adults. They're in
childhood, and they can
be also associated with
diseases of the
frontal lobe pathways,
such as grasp reflex
or pulmonary mental
response, as well as
the rooting reflex.
I won't get into them
any more than that,
just to know that they
exist. to really complete
the reflex components,
but we will get
more into that with
the pediatric lectures.
Special technique.
Okay, plantar response.
Okay, this is what
we're doing. We're
going to be testing
this. This is for an
upper motor neuron
leaching. Okay, you're
taking the back end
of your reflex hammer,
the sharp end, let
the patient know
what you're doing.
And what you're doing
is, as you can see,
the examiner strokes
the lateral aspect of
the sole of the foot
from heel to the
ball. They start down,
they start all the
way at the heel,
and go to the
ball of the foot,
going down to upward.
Okay, very, very
important to
follow that motion.
Okay, what happens
is in a normal
response, the foot
will naturally
plantar flex, it'll
move downward.
If there is an
upper motor neural
response, and it's
positive, there'll be
dorsiflexion
most commonly
seen in the first toe.
This Babinski response
refers and most
likely is indicative
of a CNS cranial nerve
lesion affecting the
corticospinal tract.
Does anyone
know when this
is normal in patients?
Yeah. So, good. I'm
sure most of you got
it, that it is normal
in children under
a certain age usually
less than a year
old, usually even
less than that. It's
about six months, but
it's a normal response
that dissipates over
time in children.
One of the final
special techniques
includes the Hoffman
test. This Hoffman test
tests for upper
motor neuron lesions
above T1. You simply,
as the picture
demonstrates, you
flick the nail of the
middle finger, and if
the thumb and second
finger flexes, it's
a positive test.
It's almost like a
pathological movement
of those two
fingers. So a patient
has neurologic symptoms
due to an upper
motor neural lesion
and not due to a
reticulopathy or
peripheral nerve lesion.
Really, it's good
to have a few of
these upper motor
neurons in your back
pocket, especially if
there is significant
neuronal injury
or diffuse axonal
injury in the patient.
Knowing if it's
upper versus lower
motor neuron, it's
key to their diagnosis
and treatment.
And here are some
special techniques
that I mentioned we
discussed before.
This is a Romberg
test. A Romberg
test is a test of
position sense, and
we'll be demonstrating
this in lab.
Essentially, you
have the patient,
you're standing
behind the patient,
making sure they
don't fall, so
you're close by with
your arms supporting
on both sides
without touching.
And you have them
put their feet
completely together
with their eyes open.
And then if there's
no loss of balance,
you have them close
their eyes for 30
to 60 seconds. If
you notice any sway
or loss of balance
with the eyes closed,
it could be a
positive test or
indicative of some
dorsal column disease.
OK, so really,
really is important
to make sure you
pay close attention
to patient safety
in this test.
Next special technique
is the pronator drift
test. Again, we'll
be practicing this
in lab with your eyes
closed and you're
standing in front of the
patient. you have them
move both arms straight
forward with palm
up and hold that
position with their eyes
closed for 20 to 30
seconds. Once that's
done, without telling
them, you do not
tell them, you tap both
arms briskly downward.
You need to get a
response. A normal
response, their arms
completely return normally
to the position that
you had when you
started them with their
arms straight out.
Any kind of problem,
if one arm and palm
turned inward and down,
as you can see in the
bottom picture, that
can also be indicative
of a portico-spinal,
tract, contralateral.
So it's important
to keep that in mind
as well. So that's
a positive test, but
we'll be practicing
this again as well.
Finally, getting into
documentation, as we
did before in the
first lecture, I'm just
giving you a demonstration
of documentation.
This slide is your
reference. You
can see how things
are written out
from the mental
status exam down to
DTRs as we went
over through before.
And then you can
go through that
as well on your
leisure. Here are
some of the
references we use.
Bates has the best
pictures as well
as Dijon's neurologic
examination.
And finally, please make
sure you come prepared
to lab. Dress in
appropriate CPR attire.
Make sure you have
those areas exposed,
which you'll be examining
for reflexes and
whatnot. And make sure
if we're doing the neuro
labs, like we might
be practicing the eye
exam again to get as much
practice as possible.
Always keep your
ophthalmoscope charged.
Bring your visual
acuity cards
if you have, as
well as penlight
tuning fork and
reflex hammer.
And please make sure
you review these skills.
Sometimes these labs
are very dense. We
don't always have time
to review every single
skill, but we do our
best to give you enough
practice time. But it
really is important
for you to come to
Lab Repair with a good
sense of what we're
going to be practicing.
And the skill sheets
are really champ
-packed with a lot of
good information for you.
Not only does it have
all the skills you
need to know, but
there's practice
neurodocumentation and
soap note documentation at
the back of each
package. So please review
these as well as your
CPG prior to the lab.
And that brings us
to the end. Thank
you very much for
your time. I will be
back again for the
final of three labs.
three lectures,
and I hope you all
have a wonderful
rest of your day.